[Musique]
c'est 200 bénéficiaires du rsa présents
aujourd'hui se retrouvent un mois après
leur engagement pour la fabrication de
masques de protection
tous se sont mobilisés pendant le
confinement sein du premier atelier
départemental semi industrielle de
production de masques en tissu le
département et ses partenaires ont remis
des attestations à tous ces volontaires
engagés dans cette action d'intérêt
général de l'encens
l'entente les portages c'est super
pendant un mois au sein de cet atelier
semi-industrielle les lignes de
production produiront 82500 masque en
tissu destiné aux réunionnais les plus
fragiles 17 couturière du syndicat de la
couture réunionnaise formeront ses
bénéficiaires souvent sans expérience
dans ce domaine
un défi de taille nécessaire au coeur de
cette crise sanitaire du coc vie 19 je
remercie les personnes bénéficiaires du
rsa qui se sont mobilisés volontairement
pour venir travailler avec nous et
encore une fois le résultat il est là
grâce à cette production mais nous avons
pu aider les personnels du département
les gramounes les personnes en situation
de handicap
bientôt nos services bravo donc c'est
énorme c'est énorme comme
comme objectif des gens ils doivent
apprendre à regarder la machine a enfilé
l'aiguillé
enfin bref tout est en même temps il
faut fabriquer moi même j'aime tes est
ce qu'on va y arriver et pour autant ces
personnes ces deux ans donner le
meilleur de ses bénéficiaires du rsa
disposent tous désormais d'une nouvelle
expérience à la fois techniques et
humaines
cette chaîne de solidarité montre une
nouvelle fois la mobilisation des
réunionnais pour faire face à cette
pandémie
[Musique]